we ask the audience about their biggest
fears and let's let's just tell the
monks just ring before you say anything
Ruffalo we'll take you down okay okay so
hands up if you got if you've got a fear
we ask me for the nice lady here what
are you afraid of the lady who made it
Rose where's rose oh there you are there
you are firstly you must have a very
tall oven fancy but how long did this
take and it took a team of four of us
about two to three weeks Wow
come over and have a look at this come
on because I'm going to get you give
your taste in a bit no because we are
allowed to eat it because now tell us
these things so that you it comes with
it comes with things these are all
available as well yes these are licorice
yes they're good eating they're really
they're a nice
how do you taste better than I imagined
yes there's an awful people in the
audience who love you so I will wait and
calm down so I'm just gonna give an
opportunity for some of them to say I
love you so so we're that oh look at her
a blue hand right up there okay what
what's your name Anna Anna and send up
where you from Anna
sorry sorry slap Harrison that's the
point now wait a minute that okay so
there he is he's not gonna you nearer
okay look them in the eyes and tell him
oh wait wait for the music I love you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one's been lovely defense that you be
very nice you go see very good David
you're a big fan but someone else in
your family is also very big fat yes my
mum's a big fan and we were in a
restaurant at the River Cafe about
probably about seven years ago my mom
had drunk a bit too much and she
suddenly felt a bit ill and I led her
outside to the table as a newest asset
one of the tables and she stopped dead
and I had to sort of drag her like you
would a donkey on a beach away not so
excited to see you
well how ill was she otherwise you've
got to let me see if I can figure out
who she is
hmm I can see her already she's blushing
she's smiling look at her look at her
[Applause]
he's a good mama's boy you're not proud
of your lad back 42 million books of it
one of these days he just might win an
Oscar
[Applause]
I'm actually afraid of sperm in places
it's not supposed to be what your
forensic scientist yes so I feel like
it's everywhere and it freaks me out I
think you should have your couch checked
out
[Applause]
I tell you what I've got I've got one of
those little CSI things
men are now singing up
oh okay so what's your name Dean Dean
okay come out here Dean put your hat
down okay Stan the lights out let's
bring the lights down it's really like
Susie oh there's Susie hiya what's the
Muir's now shopping cart
she remembered well done can you do it
in your seat or do you need to come out
and I don't need to come out Oh beauty
oh she needs to come out okay
makes the music will do the shopping
cart here we go
[Applause]
what am i doing pushing the same car
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
this myth is practitioner of the
phenomenon known as hopper hands hover
hands so it's that thing when you're
posing for a picture with someone yeah
you do the arm it's just a hopper hopper
this is a cut this is will doing hover
hands this is very this casick around
here look hard and just that Harvard
yeah but no because you is strangers you
can't just you can't just be touching
people you know but I hacked because I
had I used to have old styles of taking
pictures you know I try I tried a couple
things I'll show you how I used to so so
one of my first ones was the the you
know when I was young it was the pelvic
lead you know so this was how I usually
take pictures with all the fans and then
I felt like this wasn't you know yeah
it's not appropriate right no I switch
to the prom
[Applause]
the most approach in mind to the mass
[ __ ] Angela okay so come down here
no you sat in the front row and now
you're not in it no
okay seven stand up stand up stand up
okay oh you know you go kamiya right
here okay so we're around here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Palmer step down step down sit down
so Paul Burke look in the lens they're
ready you ready ready ready
brace yourselves a creep brace
yourselves a curry because I'm moving
the camera moving the camera
Zachary here is Lady Gaga you know
you're so famous right now you have no
idea oh there you are there you are
there is there anything like a pail of
it for the new album Oh could you do
something for him a little line of
something to blow his mind
I can't the way I'm feeling no please
take your lead
[Applause]
we'll send you a tape we'll save your
tape decorate your pure and happy and
I'm so proud of you baby thank you
[Applause]
you're a nice man I'll tell you why
because you're giving them a voice and
that's what if this is all about for me
you just gave him you gave him his
moment thank you
[Applause]
[Music]